After creating and running Saturday Night
Live for five seasons, Lorne Michaels stepped
away from the sketch comedy to work on some
other TV projects.
As a result, the show's sixth season, which
ran from 1980 to 1981, turned out to be an
incredibly tumultuous year for the creatives
on SNL.
Although much of the chaos ensued behind the
scenes, there were some on-screen shifts that
rendered the show's comedy pretty forgettable.
So forgettable, in fact, that people rarely
bring up any moments from this season at all
unless they're talking about how disastrously
bad it was.
Here's what you might not know about Saturday
Night Live's forgotten season.
Breaking away
After five years of putting in the intense
time and effort it takes to make SNL shine,
Lorne Michaels decided he needed to take a
step back from the executive chair for a bit.
At first, he just wanted the summer off and
to delay the sixth season premiere to just
after the 1980 election, instead of the usual
September start.
But Michaels also admitted he wasn't sure
if he wanted to come back at all, because
to continue the show meant he'd have to sacrifice
other ambitions.
So, he floated some ideas to NBC about who
should take over in his absence just in case.
His top choice was for SNL writers and occasional
performers Al Franken and Tom Davis to take
over.
He figured they'd be the best candidates to
maintain the quality, integrity, and tone
of the show, since they'd all worked together
for so long.
But he doomed Franken's chances before the
possibility could even materialize.
Michaels had been scheduled to meet with NBC
president Fred Silverman to discuss their
future, but Silverman had to postpone.
Then, the weekend before the rescheduled appointment,
Franken appeared on a segment of "Weekend
Update" that specifically targeted the head
honcho.
"You know who gets complete, door-to-door
limousine service from NBC?
Fred Silverman."
Franken said in the piece that it wasn't fair
that he should have to hail cabs in New York
while Silverman got to take a limousine wherever
he wanted, even while NBC was failing in the
ratings.
"I like to call it a limo for the lame-o."
Silverman saw the episode — and lost his
cool with Michaels.
The relationship between Michaels and the
network soured so badly that Michaels decided
to walk away from SNL completely, and Silverman
overlooked Franken as Michaels' replacement.
Regrouping
A few weeks after his spat with NBC brass,
Michaels got a call from another exec who
informed him that his successor would be Jean
Doumanian, an associate producer for the show.
Michaels thought Doumanian was, quote, "an
interesting choice" because he felt SNL was,
quote, "a writer-based show," and Doumanian
had been on the writing staff for exactly
one TV variety special.
But her years on SNL did give her the knowledge
of how the show was assembled each week, and
Doumanian's skills as a talent coordinator
would come in handy.
That's because when Michaels left, so did
the entire cast of Saturday Night Live: including
Jane Curtin, Bill Murray, Garrett Morris,
Laraine Newman, and Gilda Radner.
So that meant Doumanian had to assemble an
entirely new cast.
She put together a roster that included Denny
Dillon, Gilbert Gottfried, Joe Piscopo, and
Eddie Murphy.
Although Murphy was not the first choice for
the new roster, he continuously contacted
talent coordinator Neil Levy until he gave
the comedian a chance to audition.
Little did anyone know that Murphy's audition
routine would come in handy later on in the
show.
See, almost every writer left with Lorne Michaels
and the cast, so Doumanian had to recruit
a new stable of talent behind-the-scenes too.
But with the writer's room becoming its own
sort of revolving door while she was in charge,
there was a shortage of sketches.
In one case, they were running five minutes
short on material and decided at the last-minute
to have Murphy go out and perform his stand-up
routine to fill the empty airtime.
The 19-year-old became the actual saving grace
of the entire season after that.
Multiple missteps
Despite the introduction of Murphy as a rising
star, the sixth season of SNL was still filled
with snafus.
For example, In the cold open of the season
premiere, host Elliott Gould wakes up in bed
with some new cast members, and they're immediately
compared to the show's former cast members.
"Sort of a cross between Gilda and Jane."
In other words, the show's new era began with
an unfavorable comparison to its old iteration,
and it was a steep slide down from there.
In one episode, some good ol' boys try to
shoot Communists, and one character used the
N-word.
But the season wasn't just offensive — it
was also boring and bizarre.
There was a five-minute-long sketch about
a couple who can't remember the name of their
friend's cat.
"The Leather Weather Report" featured Denny
Dillon as a dominatrix named Thelma Thunder
giving her S&M-themed forecast.
Perhaps most idiotically, "Weekend Update"
was ditched in favor of a failed segment called
"Saturday Night Newsline."
And in what became the most infamous incident
of the season, on episode 11 in February,
cast member Charles Rocket dropped an eff-bomb
on live air.
“Charlie, How are you feeling after you’ve
been shot?”
“Oh man, it’s the first time I’ve ever
been shot in my life.
I’d like to know who the f--- did it.”
The show lost 30 percent of its audience,
and critics maligned the new direction.
The New York Times even called it "an unfunny
parody of its predecessor" that relied too
heavily on racial and sexual humor.
If the execs wants to salvage their hit series,
they'd have to think fast.
Beginning again
After the 12th episode of the season — one
after Charles Rocket's eff-word incident — Doumanian
was relieved from her position as SNL producer.
Her replacement was NBC executive Dick Ebersol,
who'd actually helped develop Saturday Night
Live in the mid-'70s.
Immediately after taking over, Ebersol fired
most of the cast, including Charles Rocket,
Gilbert Gottfried, Ann Risley, Yvonne Hudson,
Matthew Laurance, and Patrick Weathers.
In their places, he brought in SCTV stars
Robin Duke and Tony Rosato, as well as Tim
Kazurinsky.
Laurie Metcalf and National Lampoon editor
Emily Prager were also hired as featured players.
By the time the season was finished, Ebersol
also fired Gail Matthius and Denny Dillon,
so the only Doumanian hires to survive the
season were breakout stars Eddie Murphy and
Joe Piscopo.
Thanks to Murphy's status as the MVP of the
season, he became the first featured player
promoted to regular cast member during his
first season on the show.
Bad timing
What set all these massive changes into motion
was producer Lorne Michaels wanting a break
in the fall of 1980.
Ironically, had he just stayed with the show
and said nothing to NBC, he probably would've
gotten one.
The sixth season of SNL didn't actually air
its first episode until November 15th, 1980
— about two months late — all because
of a Screen Actors Guild strike.
But luckily for everyone involved with the
disaster-plagued season, it also ended early,
cut short abruptly after the 13th episode
due to a writers strike.
The 14th episode had already been planned,
and it might have helped get SNL back on track.
As a guest on Weekend Update, would-be showrunner
Al Franken announced he'd be back the next
week to host and offered a scathing monologue
about how he was hellbent on repairing the
broken season.
"Anyway it took NBC 12 shows to figure out
their horrendous mistake."
But the strike-shortened season led to some
of the shortest tenures in SNL history.
Featured players Laurie Metcalf and Emily
Prager were let go after that de facto season
finale, and Metcalf only appeared in one pre-taped
bit for Weekend Update, while Prager never
officially appeared on the show at all.
Thanks to the brevity of the season and so
many cast and creative shake-ups, it's hardly
any wonder why SNL's sixth season hasn't shown
up much in the highlight reel.
But, hey — at least it introduced the world
to Eddie Murphy.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!